hi everybody my name is Erica Mason I
work a third love as a data scientist
and before I get going I just wanted to
get take a quick poll how many people in
the audience are data scientists okay so
I just want you all to think back to a
time that you built some really great
model you validated it and it was doing
everything you wanted it to do
all of the metrics were looking really
great and then nothing happened with it
it just stayed on your laptop or in a
git repo and never got to where you
needed it to be in terms of in the hands
of people who are going to use it and it
just stayed on your laptop so this story
empowering business partners to make
model based marketing decisions is
really just a story about how last year
when I built a model I wanted to make
sure that that didn't happen that I
could get the model into the hands of
the decision-makers in a very
lightweight way with few resources and
before I get into that I wanted to take
another poll has anyone here heard of
third love okay more than I expected
so third love is an e-commerce company
and for those of you who don't know we
sell bras so we are part retail part
tech company and we're based out of San
Francisco we have about a hundred people
working in our San Francisco office but
we also have a pretty big office here in
Cordova of fifth of around 50 engineers
software engineers data engineers and
product managers and the reason that I
and that may seem like a lot of people
for just selling bras but it's actually
pretty complicated so this is our whole
product lifecycle from you know
marketing to sourcing the bras from our
factories and the reason that I say that
we're part retail part tech company is
that we use tech and data to give
insights for each stage of this process
to make it as effective as possible
and we have actually a team of 10 data
scientists working on improving these
processes and we're focused on three
main areas within third love that's
product marketing and then inventory and
operations the product data science team
is really focused on providing data
products to our website this includes
the fifth hour fit finder recommendation
algorithm that recommends a bra size we
also have style ranking and other site
personalization as well as a/b testing
and then our marketing data science team
which I'm going to focus a little bit
more on today focuses on making sure
that every dollar we spend on marketing
is as efficient as possible and then
finally our inventory and operations
team their main focus right now is
projecting and forecasting demand at the
SKU level so that we can buy our
inventory in an optimal way so I was
working on the marketing data science
team last year and I want to tell you a
little bit about one of the problems the
main problem we were focused on so as I
said we're an e-commerce company we're
primarily driven by performance
marketing and what this means is we
spend a lot of money on digital
marketing channels like Facebook or
Google and these are pretty
straightforward to measure in general
because we know how many people see
these ads we know how many people click
through and how many people finally make
an order with these ads but we also do
other things so for example we have
offline marketing we market on podcasts
and we market on traditional TV this
gets a lot harder to measure because we
don't have clicks anymore and then we do
other crazier stuff we're not crazy just
old-school stuff like putting ads and
newspapers and magazines
and also we send out little postcards to
people in the mail so once you have all
these different marketing methods it
becomes really hard to measure the
impact of any of these channels and hard
to determine where we should be
allocating our money so this was the
problem we were facing and as data
scientists what did we do we built a
model so our input was the amount of
marketing spend we were spending in each
of these marketing channels at different
time points and our response variable
was our orders over time and that sounds
pretty straightforward but there were a
lot of issues we had to deal with the
fact that this is time series data so we
had to deal with seasonality and trend
an autocorrelation also with this
marketing data and we had to deal with
the fact that there's diminishing
returns the more we spend in any of
these channels the less efficient we get
as we start to saturate our audience
there's also synergistic effects between
these channels that we had to deal with
and actually I'm not really want to get
into too much how we solved this model
but this is the functional the the model
that we fit and I actually documented
how we solved this how we validated our
model in our blog and also wrote a white
paper about it and talked about some
common gotchas that you deal with in
building these media mix models but what
I really want to talk today about today
is what we did with this model next so
we had this model as I said it was great
we did back tests we validate it with
experimental data we felt like it was
really ready to start being used by our
marketing partners who could use it to
make decisions and they were excited
about it too they you know had been
shooting in the dark and wanted to
understand how effect how they should be
spending more efficiently the problem
was that there was no way for them to
interact with this model
they just didn't it was all in high
scripts on my laptop and they had no way
to you know ask it questions so what did
we do they asked me and I would run
scripts so I was just standing in the
middle between the marketing team and
this model as a go-between they would
ask me questions I would run scenarios
and get back to them it's very iterative
and time-consuming and this was
obviously not a great solution not
scalable at all it became very clear
that we needed to build some sort of
tool for them to interact with this
model so once that was clear we just had
to figure out what should this tool what
go into this tool how are we gonna do it
what just what are the key things that
need to be included for them to get what
they needed out of it and you know at
the time this was over a year ago we
were a pretty small company and all of
our engineering and product management
resources we're really focused on our
website making our website as efficient
as possible you know getting people
through that funnel to make an order we
didn't have people focused on internal
tools so it's clear that it was up to
the data science team to provide this
tool to the marketing team so I'm not a
product manager but the two questions I
was thinking at the time were how am I
gonna do this and what needs to go in
there
so first focusing on the how I started
googling and I started talking to
colleagues and people in the community
and three frameworks really bubbled up
as platforms that data scientists used
to build kind of interactive dashboards
and visualizations and those three were
dashed by plotly boca and shiny for me I
ruled out shiny right away because I'm a
Python person and I wouldn't be here
presenting about it if I didn't are and
then between the other two I just did a
lot of research and I don't work for any
of these companies but I ended up
working with - and there were a few
things that I liked about it firstly
it's built on a flask back-end which I
knew our engineering team was already
familiar with so I knew I could get help
with deployment later on the other thing
I liked is that it's kind of a direct
translation from HTML into Python so if
you're familiar with HTML you don't have
to relearn anything there's a very small
learning curve it also plugs in directly
with plotly visualizations which I'd
used before and I also found that the
getting started guide was really great
so that for me at the time was just the
tool that I thought was best for the job
and then what should go into this tool
what are the questions that the
marketing team need answered and there
were a lot of things we could have done
with this model we can assess past
performance we can predict into the
future but really the question they
wanted to know and it kept coming up
time and time again is how much money
should we be spending in each time and
not only that but they added a lot of
caveats like
oh by the way you can't spend that much
money in this channel they they don't
have the capacity for that or we don't
actually have a TV commercial that's
gonna be ready next quarter so we can't
spend in TV or oh we already bought the
paper for our postcards so we have to
spend this much um so these were the
kinds of questions I was getting over
and over again and this brought me back
to my time at university studying
operations research because it reminded
me of a constrained optimization problem
so how can I I needed to figure out how
can I turn those questions I was being
asked into an optimization problem that
we can solve so here we formulated that
into an optimization problem where X is
the amount of money that we spend in
each marketing channel and then we want
to maximize our total orders this
formula here is the same model that we
were using before to fit to fit based on
our data and now we're using those
parameters that we fit as constants and
solving for the spend and then we have a
set of constraints we said that each
channel has a certain budget and that in
total we can only spend a certain amount
of money and again the question became
Hari and I solved this in Python how am
I going to put this into my dash
application and that's where CVX PI
comes in again I don't work for this or
and affiliated in any way but it's a
package that I used that I really liked
and I want to share so CVX PI was
developed at Stanford by a research
group there and their tagline is convex
optimization for everyone so the things
I really like about it as long as you
have an optimization problem that fits
into this convex optimization framework
which we do this is the objective
function there is a convex function as
long as those beta parameters add up to
less than 1 and we have linear
constraints we can formula and all we
have to do is formulate that function
pretty much in numpy syntax throw it in
to throw it in to an objective function
define our constraints put
into this CVX pie problem object and
solve using any solver you want so what
I liked is the math and the code look
really similar and it's very
straightforward I don't know to know how
it's being solved so given that I wanted
to just quickly show you the demo of
what we built for the marketing team and
this is just a toy example of the first
version we built but basically we were
able to give them something where they
can put in their budget to be optimized
a month that they want to optimize for
and then a table where they can input
constraints for each of the channels and
then they can also specify things like
how much do we think of the average
order value is going to be what do we
think the return rates going to be how
many bras do we have in stock this month
say it's 40 and then CVX PI runs the
optimization we get an output of our
total orders gross revenue net revenue
and our return on adspend and then down
here is what they really cared about
which is the optimized spend by channel
and it gives us an indication of how
much we should be spending in each
channel what the model thinks is the
average cost and average and marginal
cost of each of these marketing inputs
and then here are these plotly
visualizations that you know this one is
just to show what we should expect the
gross revenue to be every day so that
they can tell if they're on target and
then the just the overall breakdown of
how much the model thinks we should be
spending in each channel and what was
great about this was because I they
could run this optimization and then
they could look at the results and say
oh well five hundred thousand dollars in
marketing channel D that's not possible
there's no way we can spend that much
we'll over saturate our audience so they
could just go in right away and maybe
change it to three hundred thousand
and have it reoptimize and reallocate
the money without having you know me in
the middle going back and forth on email
so I just want to show you a little bit
of some of those features that I showed
you what the code looks like
so that table where I could edit and
input any numbers I want all that is is
pulling in this - data table component
initializing it with a panda's data
frame and setting editable equal to true
and then doing a few style things and
you can see like the other code we're
using divs and headers similar to HTML
that's what I was talking about when I
say it's a direct translation from HTML
into Python same thing with these
sliders it's super easy you just are
importing this - core component slide or
object and initializing it and then the
pie chart as well you're just feeding it
into these ready-to-go core components
that dash has and this example I showed
you was pretty simple you can do a lot
cooler stuff with - so one more thing if
you're paying attention closely I
started talking about how this is all
about getting the model into the hands
of our marketing partners but really all
I've been talking about now is
developing an application locally on my
laptop so we had to call in the big guns
at this point which was our data
engineering team so we called a Mis guy
Marco's who's sitting right there and
he's from Cordova Airport of a team and
he went to university here just for
background and basically what he did was
he took my - application which that
back-end was in flask he integrated
Amazon kognito with it for authorization
and authentication so that only certain
people in our company could log on with
their third loved email addresses he put
that into a docker image and hosted on
Heroku and that was great so we had this
application we had it at a URL that
people could log in to safely and
securely and run any scenarios they
wanted but the question here now became
so what like what did this actually give
us as a
company um and the first thing that it
gave us was really just a shared
understanding of how the model worked
when I was sitting between our business
partners and the model you know running
scenarios with me in the loop it didn't
give them time to interact with the
model itself and so they didn't have an
intuition of how it worked it was really
just a black box that spat things out
once they were able to play with it
themselves they had a much better
intuition of what inputs cause what
outputs how the whole thing was working
and this really created like a magic
moment where they were able to start
giving me feedback on my model so as
marketing experts they know a lot more
about marketing than I do and they could
tell if something was wrong so the first
thing was easy like they could just give
me feedback on bugs like if something
wasn't working we were able to move a
lot faster once I had more eyes working
on this project but the other thing was
they were also able to challenge key
assumptions that I was making in my
model an example of this is that at
first when I built this we included a
channel called branded search and this
channel is basically if someone typed in
third love into a search engine like
Google or Bing or whatever search engine
and then we pay for Google to show our
ad at the top and that only had this is
branded so it's only if they type in
third love so people who type in third
love into search engines already know
about us they're looking for our website
they're very high intent and they're
very likely to make an order so
originally my model thought this channel
was the best thing ever
it was trying to when we when it came to
optimization it was telling us to spend
you know 75 percent of our spend in
branded search and this just isn't even
possible because we can't spend in this
channel unless someone types our name
into the into the search engine and
people don't type your name into the
search engine unless you're advertising
on other channels so it's just flawed a
flawed assumption that we should include
it and we ended up taking it taking it
out of the model and because it was
highly correlated with this men and
other channels this
improving our bottle performance as well
the other thing that happened with this
shared understanding was that the
marketing partners were able to trust us
a lot or trust the model a lot more when
they had an intuition of how it worked
when the model spat out something crazy
they weren't just dismissing it right
away they you know would try and figure
out why is it doing that
what are the limitations here either
give me feedback on if I thought
something was wrong or use the
constraints to just account for
something that they knew the model
couldn't account for and that was really
great because that first one it was more
of a black box if it just spat out
something crazy they would be like okay
well we can't use this anymore because
it sucks so that was great and then the
other thing that this model having the
model available to them to interact with
was that it really fostered more of a
testing culture within our marketing
team so our marketing team always was
testing within channels so for example
with Facebook they would always be
testing okay is this ad set better than
this ad set doing a/b testing that way
but this model kind of reoriented all of
us to be thinking about what is the
value of spend in in facebook at all or
any channel at all so it started us to
reorient around hold out tests where we
would have you know our control groups
wouldn't be a different ad set it would
be not showing ads at all so that we
could really measure the incremental
value of each of these channels and one
of the reasons this actually started is
because this model would spit out don't
spend any money in some channels and
this is where I have to give major kudos
to the marketing team because you know
imagine you're in charge of a certain
channel and then a data scientist comes
along and tells you hey the Chandler
that you've spent the last year trying
to optimize isn't worth anything it's
not driving orders at all I mean that's
a lot to take
but our marketing team was able to take
that and then devise tests to validate
whether that
is true not just take the models output
at face value but devise tests to
validate whether it's true and then
iterate from there and this actually led
to the marketing team completely cutting
spend in actually two channels last year
and drastically reducing spend in
another channel so that was really cool
to see that we were actually you know
making data-driven decisions as a
company and that's once we did that we
were immediately able to drive more
efficiency and that was really the value
of this model is that once we drove more
efficiency we were able to sell more
bras which is our goal and provide women
all over the US and you know they're
perfect fit and so the real takeaway
here is not anything about marketing or
these two packages I talked about or
anything like that but the takeaway here
is that getting a good model into the
hands of decision-makers is way more a
valuable use of your time than trying to
eke out like one more percentage of
accuracy or some other metric so I think
I went through that pretty fast but if
you have any questions
[Applause]
I hello thank you for your talk
I completely agree that the the key
point in here is how to put your models
in the hands of the correct people but I
still don't understand about that so I'm
going to ask you a technical question
when you're using this visualization
tool what's the trade-off between how
much you can modify your visualization
versus how standardized is the is the
library's kind of like between Seaborn
Matt lovely in that spectrum where is it
I think it definitely depends on what
you're trying to do for us the
visualization wasn't the most important
thing it was really being able to have
an a tool where they could input any
inputs they wanted for constraints and
spit that out
the I think that in this case the
dashboard would have been just as
effective if we didn't even have any
visualizations at all but it definitely
depends case-by-case
hello thanks for the presentation so it
was really cool to for the marketing
team to take decisions but I was
thinking like the next step is probably
them validating if the decision was like
the correct one so let's say if you
predict that the world gross revenues
would be X they need to check if the
decision actually made the gross revenue
should be X do you have like an
integration between the this decision
platform and maybe monitoring if the
decisions and the performance were as
expected how do you do that's a great
question and we're always trying to
improve on that different ways we
validate this model are a few things
when we do back tests so we hold out our
months of data and predict on it the
other thing we do is with our
experimental data at the channel level
for holdout tests we get an a cost per
incremental acquisition from those
holdout tests and compare that to what
the model is spitting out at the channel
level but then you have an another great
point like what about holistically when
we're predicting this allocation is that
actually providing the gross revenue we
think and the question the answer is we
don't have like an automated validation
built into the tool yet but I think
that's a great idea the other problem is
there a lot of stuff comes up day-to-day
in terms of marketing and just business
trends so even if it's not exactly right
we can still say that it's a good tool
because for example say like we have a
big article come out about us that
totally changes what our gross revenue
is gonna be but we do use those back
tests to try and validate the model and
the other thing is we don't know we
don't have like a counterfactual of what
would have happened had we not used
these spend recommendations but and I
didn't mention this we have actually
been able to increase our marketing
budget from last year to this year by
40%
while increasing our return on adspend
and this is really difficult to do
because normally when you scale your
marketing you become less efficient
because you're reaching a broader
audience and you're reaching diminishing
returns so between this tool and it's
not just this tool it's other efforts
that have been done by our data science
marketing team we've been able to beat
that trend and scale our program while
increasing return but yeah I think
that's a great point to actually
integrate it into the tool hi you thank
you for the talk I got more on the
technical side question do you need to
retrain model from time to time and how
do you handle that it's automated in
some way or do we need to retrain it
yourself and then publish it yes so we
need to retrain this model about once a
month just because the trend terms of
like how the business is doing really
affect the model so the way that we we
retrain it and rerun back tests every
month and then redeploy it to the tool
thank you
hello thank you um I have a question are
you familiar with our markdown yes I
wish there was something like our
markdown in Python and I've been
considering learning - as an alternative
to it but it the way you make it sound
it's like it's more like developing a
whole app a web application or something
but could could it be an option if you
have like a like a jupiter notebook or a
python script that you can just sort of
pop it up and show it in a way that or
is it in involved process I would say
from what I was using it for so I'm
oriented that I was using it for this
application so I'm not a hundred percent
sure you couldn't but I would say it's
probably not the best tool for that
because it is really more focused around
building an application but anyone can
challenge that here
[Music]